so today's such a major news day that
I'm not even talking about the fact that
there was a mass shooting at a school
yesterday which also tells us a lot
about how commonplace those shootings
are how we've been become so
desensitized in a way that it's not even
making the show today but I will try to
give my thoughts on it tomorrow as well
as Donald Trump tweeting condolences to
a different mass shooting after
yesterday's mass shooting tomorrow today
some stunning world news actually the
Zimbabwean military has taken over
control of the country from longtime
dictator President Robert Mugabe and he
along with his wife are reportedly under
house arrest however the term coup or
the term military takeover is sort of
being rejected by the military itself
television and radio announcements from
the military said this is not a military
takeover which is kind of funny because
when the military takes control of the
airwaves in order to tell you anything
you sort of think of it as a military
takeover but there there's actually a
lot of legal significance or at least PR
significance in saying it is not a coup
in terms of how this takeover I don't
even know what other word to use is
going to be seen internationally and
we'll talk about those implications but
practically speaking there's every
indication that this is a coup it looks
like a coup it sounds like a coup and it
definitely smells like a coup military
vehicles all over the city of Harare the
army taking over a TV station uniformed
members of the military issuing
statements to the country and the
international legitimacy of this you
know if you say this is a coup it sounds
very anti progressive rightly so but
really the question as to whether this
is or isn't a military coup is going to
be based on what comes next right will
there be democratic elections next year
as presumably scheduled to take place
and the timing of it is interesting it's
probably more than interesting I'm
struggling for the right word because
Robert Mugabe is 93 years old he has
been president since 1987
in Zimbabwe he before being president
for seven years was the Prime Minister
from 1980 to 1990 nay t7 so it's easy to
say well listen taking him out of power
at age 93 it's not meaningless but he's
pretty frail for now right like what
what really is the meaning of saying hey
we waited 37 years and now we've taken
him out of power but really the question
is what comes next
right when dictators come to the ends of
their lives what happens next is what
really matters and there's been the
possibility discussed that his wife
Grace Mugabe who's much younger than him
52 years old which which makes her 41
years younger than Robert Mugabe she was
considered maybe set to take over for
him but they're both now in military
custody and reportedly safe under house
arrest
there are Mugabe defenders who rightly
point out wait he's not really the bad
guy that he's been made out to be
he took the country away from white
minority rule as Prime Minister in 1980
but the problem is that after doing that
in 1980 as Prime Minister he became this
brutal suppressor of dissent of any kind
made decisions that led to just
astronomical inflation more and more
poverty and the political question now
is does Mugabe say I'm stepping down
which is what the military will
presumably try to get him to do he's on
house arrest right but actually getting
him to relinquish the presidency is what
would need to happen to allow an acting
president to take control for example
now the upside is that so far this all
appears to have happened without
violence early reports so far this is in
its in its very early stages but Mugabe
is reportedly as I said already safe and
under house arrest bloodshed
common maybe as an overstatement but not
that rare when it comes to these
situations the downside or the possible
downside is that anytime you have a
military removing a dictator from power
you have the possibility that the
replacement can end up being just as bad
or even
and we have a number of examples of that
that we've talked about on the program
over the last many years and we'll have
to see what happens with that I saw some
rumblings of could North Korea be next
might the North Korean military do this
to Kim jong-un I don't think it's likely
I mean we there's a totally different
power structure in North Korea
drastically different circumstances in
North Korea and yes there are two
dictators in Zimbabwe and in North Korea
but that's more or less where the
similarities end so I have not for a
very I've never expected and I don't
remember if producer Lewis ever thought
that you might see a military coup in
North Korea I've never expected it and I
still don't and we'll follow the
Zimbabwe story but I don't think that it
means anything about what we might
expect to see in North Korea I think the
similarities end at there's two
dictators in these two countries the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership